but we begin with the chief weather
caster that's Lonnie Quinn of our New
York station WCBS he's got the newest
information for you from the National
Hurricane Center
Lonnie good morning last hour you told
us it's moving slower than expected yeah
that's a problem you get a storm this
size and it's got this kind of a punch
to it you want it to get in and get out
I mean it's inevitable now it's it's
it's this is Florida storm and it has
slowed up it's now moved I'll give you
those current stats move moving now
currently at 8 miles per hour take a
look
here's your eye okay now it's the eye
wall that you fear the most and sure
enough the worst that the storm has to
offer for the Florida Keys is being felt
right now anywhere from Big Pine Key
Cudjoe Key over towards Key West this is
the worst of it right there this is your
eye wall very shortly Big Pine Key give
yourself literally within a half an hour
you'll get into the eye wall and I know
how hurricane salve you are on the
Florida Keys but you're in the eye
you'll be into the eye and you catch a
little break you get about a 20 mile
break with this eye but then you're
gonna hit by the back side as well and
again I'm sure you you've been through
the drill before you know it but you got
to stay hunkered down 130 mile per hour
maximum winds as of right now moving
Northwest at 8 we just talked about that
too slow too slow in my book we want
that to go faster 20 miles
east-southeast from Key West that's the
eye again the eye wall currently on
shore let me show you the track from the
National Hurricane Center we will find
out if we have anything changed here and
nope it still moves over the Florida
Keys as a cat 4 and then it's either
going to be on land or offshore again
anywhere in the yellow cone here's a
possibility the skinny white line please
don't pay soul attention to that does
have it sort of hugging the coastline
look if it stays offshore it's allowed
to maintain its strength longer and push
all that water onshore again it's this
it's the west coast of Florida we're
very fearful about that storm surge nor
let's go over to you really important
point Lonnie thank you so much we
appreciate it